and then also you can't you can't
tell other people's kids not to do stuff
right so you got to kind of like be
loudly like hey he's climbing up on the
utility pole and kind of hope that
somebody does something
well back in the day you could yell at
people's kids and i think that that
needs to come back and that's what's
holding back this country
how have you been and what have you been
doing oh man nothing compared to you
congratulations on young harry oh thank
you very much yeah he's a great boy i
understand yeah you have a son also i
have a son yeah a little older
he's uh
i want to say
he's 10 or 15. the point is this
you i want to give you a little advice
first of all they get less cute
oh yeah and uh you gotta when they're
young you gotta do certain things for
instance what because you love your
child more than anything obviously and
when i was young and i had my little boy
dagwood
name his name is dagwood
i named him after the literary uh figure
dagwood bumpstead
yeah
now his name is dylan named after dylan
thomas because my father read me a a
child's christmas in wales every
christmas so when you're when the kid's
young
as dylan was i used to play basketball
with him and i would always let him win
because i figured that was the thing to
do as a father now he's 16 years old and
he can beat me easily
now
he thinks that he's always been able to
beat me i told him i said no no i used
to let you win he's like no
um
so my advice is beat the hell out of
harry
while i can while you can
i'm not sure that i can even now
as a little boy right now old you buddy
how old
18
shut the [ __ ] up
[Applause]
your balls haven't even dropped yet
there's no way you're 18.
18
18.
[Applause]
is that the age you're supposed to be i
mean
in here i mean you're 18.
does your body know about it
you look like you're nine
who are you with tonight
your parents okay
so mom and dad you is he really 18
what happened is he okay
man what's your name
sheil
wow
that's amazing sheil
and does he always look like a child
like when he was born was he just a
sperm or something was he
[Applause]
the doctor congratulations it's a boy
[Applause]
18 bro he looked younger did we get a
shot at him already because he looks
look at that hey
you don't even have your first mustache
yet that's
that's an indian right up every all the
girls in here have them already and you
don't
[Music]
[Applause]
you got a girlfriend
you don't
[Music]
you don't want to say because your
parents are right there
have you been
giving him the shield meal
how you doing
what's your name sir
walt
i know what the [ __ ] walters
have people had problems with your name
before sir
i understand if your name is like ahmed
or something like that like
like ahmed like you're getting something
out of your throat like
you know
miss what is your name
andrea see how it just stopped after
that
a normal introduction
how long have you guys been married
17 years that's beautiful they don't
care but that's beautiful
do you guys have any kids
no kids at all that's what i'm talking
about walt disney
so i'm talking about walt
pull out king right here bruh
every time walt pulls out like we ain't
going to disney world at all
[Applause]
so really so you guys made a decision
early on said we're not having any kids
were your parents okay with that
they were upset
your name is andrea
are you italian
what what are you
you don't know
you're russian
it's russian so your russian parents
were like you have to have more kids
you have to you must have kids
that's the whole thing about your
culture even the dolls are like look
there's more right
it's like they put that in you early on
they're like
this is your purpose in life look what
you do more and more and more
get smaller smaller smaller
so mom got pissed off
is she still pissed off
now here's the thing that's interesting
to me the mom gets pissed off she says i
want you to have kids right
but what she's really saying is
i want
walt to in you
she's not saying it but she's just like
leave it inside leave it inside
did she ever sit you down wall
never once
put it in her magic kingdom
you ever see kids
and think man be cool
never once
i think there's a lot of people in here
with kids they're looking you like
she was right she was
she was [ __ ] right
i'm paying 45 for a babysitter it's
probably molesting them right now
[Applause]
and walt you didn't want any kids
you just wanted toys
you want the kids toys
this is one creepy [ __ ]
is that why you're not having kids with
him
because he might like kids too much
if he's playing with their toys what we
do with them no no we're not doing it
we're not doing it
[Music]
having fun is a very difficult job the
reason why i say that is because kids
don't know how to shut fun off
kids think fun lasts forever i'mma tell
you the scariest [ __ ] in the world for a
man to see after a long day of work
long day at work you get home you put
your key in the door you open up that
door real slow scariest [ __ ] in the
world for a man to see is that baby with
all that energy
on the other side
oh yeah
daddy home it's time to play
i want to play daddy
i've been taking naps with mommy all day
i want to play that game when you try to
close your eyelids and i keep opening
them back up
oh yeah
it's time to play daddy
[Music]
i'll make a bet
i make a bet right now that every man in
this room that has a child has done what
i'm about to say at least one time
at least one time
long day working in your car you're
driving home
you pull in your driveway when you pull
your driveway that baby with all that
energy runs to the window opens up the
blinds oh yeah
daddy home it's time to play
you see the baby in the blinds the
babies see you you and the baby are
looking at each other you locked eyes
with the goddamn baby you staring at the
baby the baby's staring at you
and you back out the driveway
you back out the goddamn driveway [ __ ]
that baby today
i'd rather go back to work and throw
boxes at the goddamn wall to deal with
that baby today
where you going daddy [ __ ] you baby
[ __ ] you
baby
you're only laughing because it's true
how was your summer what'd you do
anything good it was great it was a lot
of fun i went i have a little boy you
know how old your son he's six years old
oh that's great i want to say six and
he's a lot of fun i do things with him
you know we play and stuff what do you
do what kind of thing i took him to
disney world well there you go down in
florida you ever go there i've never
been there well you don't have you're a
baron you're not barren but you're not
true
that's right
i'm i'm infertile
and i possibly have children
i don't mean that i mean you don't have
children i don't have any currently no
no
so but i got to tell you man if you ever
have kids i hope yeah then you should
take have you been talking to somebody
at the lab normal
[Laughter]
now but disney world has a beautiful
place
yeah so you can get to see it what's
your son's name timmy little dylan
little dylan yeah yeah dylan named for
bob dylan yeah i named her for bob dylan
and i thought hey man nobody's going to
be named dylan that's a cool name
because when i was a kid i always read
dylan
thomas dylan thomas a child's christmas
and whale yeah
so i said hey that nobody will have that
name and then everybody has that name
because that they had that kid on a
90210 this is too long right
you know after that discussion of my
fertility i don't much care
the point is he's a good well-behaved
boy and i took him to disney world there
we had a lot of fun my god we went to
the uh
they have a new thing they you know
usually they have the goofy uh pluto you
know the regular uh characters but they
also have actual animals in a safari
park oh yeah yeah wild dangerous jungle
beast yeah and you take your child
through and you see and it's a lot of
fun except they don't tell you
that they're not wearing any pants
you know like goofy and pluto right
what are you what are you talking about
goofy you know how you know what in the
world are you talking about
you know when you see mickey mouse
mickey mouse is a cartoon character he's
always got some trouble he always has
pants on that's right right well the the
dangerous uh lion and elephant they have
no
those are real actual living beings
right they're not animated cartoon
characters exactly but i'm a living
being i don't want my child to see my
you know uh thing right
that's what i'm saying i don't want my
child it's fine for you completely
different species norm a completely
different species it's a whole different
deal i'm not offended by it myself but
children ask questions and you have to
go what's that thing there between the
elephant
a big giant god-awful looking thing
i don't know
sounds like you have a very special
child norm i know
maybe you find it very attractive
i
it's just i don't see it as a problem
it's just like it's a it's a rhinoceros
eddie it's just a rhinoceros but what
would you say is the thing that i just
say it's it's it's it's his wallet it's
where he
it's very cute
this is a little it's a shaving kit
that's where he keeps his hat
some change and a comb yeah
maybe if you had a few more dollars in
your wallet you'd have a kid
[Applause]
i bet you will have a nice kid one day
you'd be a great father
[Laughter]
you hate me now because there's stuff
about your testicles
[Applause]
when guests come on the show and discuss
my testicles
it's one of my favorite things